all right we've got a few high clouds
we're going to have more of those clouds
coming in today checking the pollen
report we still have ragweed chino
sagebrush chino just various asundry
reeds and plants that bloom all summer
long those are low to close to moderate
but we'll keep them in the low category
overall good air quality even with the
high clouds coming in today
we've got a lot of 40s especially around
the fringes of the valley interior
valley still sitting right at 50 degrees
green valley the strip downtown red rock
at 40 34 up there at kyle canyon so our
normal high for this time in october 79
we're going to get a little closer today
at 74 yesterday we're at 71 so we're
kind of on a warming trend record high
for today's 95. wow that was way back in
1940 that was kind of boomtown days
closer to that sunrise 6 53 and 5 58 is
the sunset so we're going to have high
clouds mixed with sunshine between
sunrise and sunset it's all coming off
the system pushing rain and snow into
the west and it is a big welcome mat
there's a big welcome mat set up right
there on the west coast northern
california needs the rain and central
california where they've been having
those big wildfires all summer and early
fall see the high clouds here they come
they're getting pushed into nevada so
we'll get a taste of those today mixed
with sunshine mid 70's for highs a
little warmer than yesterday 71 so that
will feel good keeping light winds so
tomorrow we add a few more degrees upper
70s and friday our warmest day at 82.
now we'll get more clouds for the
weekend so partly cloudy both saturday
sunday with mid 70s before a stronger
system drops down south and right into
the desert to give us a chance of
showers and boy we'll take the rain too
on monday if we can get it